I'm Greg Allen and I've been driving
this ferry here for 14 years and I got
to meet I never thought I'd stand here
today and say on the operator the ferry
but some things have gone on and times
moved on and now I've been appointed by
the team which counts as the operator of
the ferry so we found this ferry was in
a pretty bad condition and it had a very
poor survey report on it and John it's
now down in totnes after the water
something I don't think any of us ever
thought we would see being completely
rebuilt which is absolutely amazing
because we really now don't want to lose
our historic ferry it's it's run across
a river it's just after the war and it's
loved by many people even now people
stop being the street and say what's
happening with a ferry so there's a lot
of public support me 2,000 for it and
here we are and it's great to see it
being put back to rights what are your
plans for the ferry when you do get
about the mall so um obviously
immediately let's let's get it on the I
must have it now is the frustrating time
for me we have no ferry and there's lots
of paperwork lots of things to be done
so I'm now let's get back on the water
and get some of our passengers back
hopefully the the the faces we know well
people even not necessarily locals but
people come on holiday every year they
come the same week they've been coming
for many many years and part of their
holidays to come on the ferry so get
back on the water pick our local
passengers up and then hopefully see our
regular holiday passengers through the
year and when all this one was completed
all the works hopefully she will be
sitting ready for sea and carry on for
another 25 30 years she's given 64 years
of service up to now and I'm sure she
could make me under if he hooked after
probably because the actual wood in the
boat she's built of launched on canadian
rock own timbers and she's she's in good
condition she really is what